Most processes in our universe are time reversible in other words the physics works the same way forwards or backwards
Which is why you can't tell if I'm playing these videos normally or in reverse
People typically point to entropy as the only exception to this rule. The second law of thermodynamics
states that the entropy of a system or the amount of disorder always increases with time *buzzer sound*
But increasing entropy is an emergent property, the result of the motions of many many particles
Which raises the question:
Can fundamental particles themselves tell the direction of time?
Or, in other words, is there a physical process on the scale of individual particles that looks different
forwards vs backwards? The answer surprisingly is yes.
In particle physics there are three major symmetries that were always expected to hold: charge, parity, and time.
Time symmetry, as we've already discussed, means interactions work the same way forwards or backwards in time
Charge symmetry means interactions are unaffected if all the charges are swapped in other words
there is nothing special about what we call positive charge. Nature treats it exactly equal and opposite to negative charge
and parity symmetry means the laws of physics are indifferent to left- or right-handedness.
Now to understand what that means imagine a giant mirror were held up to our universe
and in the mirror the z direction Is reversed and my right hand becomes my left hand
but the laws of physics shouldn't care I mean
they should work exactly the same way in the mirror world as they do in the regular one
with no preference for left- or right-handedness or to put it another way
there should be no experiment that you could do that would tell you whether or not you are in the mirror world
Each of these symmetries is known by its initials- C, P, and T
in the 1950s it was thought that all fundamental particles obey these symmetries
But then in 1956 a paper written by Li and Yang pointed out that parity symmetry
had actually never been tested in experiments involving the weak force
So at Christmas break that year physics professor Chien Shang Wu of Columbia University had planned
to go on vacation with her husband who is also a physicist
but instead, so intrigued by the possibility that the weak force might violate parity, she decided to stay behind
And be the first person to test it. To do this she and a team of
Low-temperature scientists cooled a collection of cobalt-60 atoms to just three thousandths of a degree above absolute zero
Then they applied a strong magnetic field to align all the nuclei with their spin pointing in the same direction
Now cobalt 60 is radioactive and it decays via the weak nuclear force releasing a beta particle
Which is just an electron and what the experiment measured was the direction in which these electrons were emitted
Relative to the spin of the cobalt 60 nuclei. To see how this would work under parity symmetry
Let's consider the mirror image version of this experiment in the mirror the direction of the z axis is flipped
But the direction of nuclear spin is not that's because an object
That's rotating clockwise is still rotating clockwise in the mirror
So this means that the spins of the regular and mirror nuclei are aligned the mirror experiment is actually the same
Experiment as the original now when a cobalt 60 nucleus decays and emits an electron that electron
Could go say to the left or to the right
Now if parity symmetry is respected the electrons should be equally likely to go in any direction
That way both the normal and mirror image experiments would give the same results however if the electrons were emitted in one direction
preferentially say in the positive z direction
well
Then in the mirror experiment the electrons would also have to fly off
preferentially in the mirror positive Z direction which is opposite to the original positive z direction
So in the normal experiment the electrons would be emitted say opposite the direction of nuclear spin, but in the mirror version
They'd be emitted in the same direction as nuclear spin, so how does this make any sense it would allow you to determine?
Whether you're in the mirror world or not
It's like the spinning top from Inception if the electrons from the cobalt 60 nuclei
Go one way, you're in mirror world and if they go the other way
You know you're in normal world now crazy as this may seem. This is exactly what professor Wu saw
Electrons were emitted preferentially in one direction and not just by a little bit
They were predominantly emitted opposite nuclear spin, so not only does the weak force violate parity
It comes close to violating parity as much as is physically possible
This destroyed a basic assumption of theoretical physics that had been around for decades
Somehow the universe cares about left or right-handed nests when wu announced her results
They shocked the physics world after being told of the experiment famous physicist and Nobel laureate
Wolfgang Pauli said "That's total nonsense," and insisted the result was mistaken when the experiment was independently replicated
Theoretical physicists had to accept that the universe we live in is not the one they had imagined the Nobel Prize was actually awarded for
The discovery of parity violation in 1957 the very same year these results were published
This required a profound shift in thinking for physicists, but before throwing everything out and starting again from scratch
They formulated a workaround
Maybe it was okay that the weak force broke parity because it's not a real
symmetry of the universe itself just part of a larger symmetry charge parity or CP symmetry
The idea was if the mirror flipped not only these axes
But it also swapped the particles for anti particles with their charges reversed
well
Then the symmetry would be restored and the mathematics behind our laws of physics would still work now this gave physicists some comfort until in
1964 it was found that some particles can also violate the combined charge parity symmetry and
Boom you got yourself another Nobel Prize now two rules which physicists once thought were fundamental laws of nature were broken so
They retreated behind their last set of theoretical defenses the combined symmetry of CP T where T is time
Sure, they said the weak force violates parity and charge
Parity, but certainly not charge parity and time together and to this day physicists are still pretty sure that CP T is a real
Symmetry of the universe so far no experiment has found a violation of CPT in fact if CP T is
Violated we would have to rewrite a lot of the last century's work because it would mean that special relativity and quantum
Field theory are both wrong ok
So let's say that CP T
Is a true symmetry think about the implications of this if we know that CP can be violated?
But CP t cannot, then time symmetry must also be broken
otherwise there would be no way for the combined three-way symmetry to be maintained while two of the sub symmetries are broken and
Physicists have actually conducted
Experiments that confirm that certain particles directly break time symmetry
For example when a pair of quarks are held together by the strong force there are sometimes two different possible
Arrangements and they can switch back and forth between these two arrangements via the weak force
But switching in one direction takes longer than switching back
So if you could make a recording of this event it would look different
If you played the recording forwards than if you played it backwards and that's exactly what it means to break time symmetry in
Certain cases then fundamental particles can tell the difference between going forwards and backwards in time
The second law of thermodynamics is not the only physical process that prefers one direction in time
Now is this the origin of our perception that time only goes one way, or is it the reason for the universe's arrow of time?
The truth is that we still have no idea why time only goes in one direction
What's interesting is that physicists once thought that parity charge and time were these symmetries that were unbreakable?
But over time each of these symmetries was demonstrably violated
So is the ultimate symmetry CPT also unbreakable or will it fall taking quantum field theory and special relativity with it?
These are just some of the big basic unresolved mysteries left in our quest to understand the universe
Perhaps one day another physicist will give up their vacation to figure out the answer
This episode of veritasium was animated and co-written by my friend jorge
Cham who is also the creator of PhD comics and now he's written a book. Yeah. It's called we have no idea
It's a book
I wrote with physicist Daniel Weitz in' and it's about all the things we don't know about the universe although the big things like
dark matter and dark energy
But also all the little things like what are all those fundamental particles for and it has cartoons in it
Yep, and lots of bad puns, so that's like. It's up your alley. You should check it out
I'll put a link to it in the description and Olive core has other projects. Thanks